c'est un labyrinthe souterrain qui
s'étire sur plusieurs centaines de
mètres
ces murs or ni cool et blanches plonge
dans des eaux cristallines cette caverne
a été découverte en 2017 par les
spéléologues daniel caron il luc leblanc
j'ai certaines de ces espèces grand plan
d'eau où parfois on voit 30 40 50 m en
face de nous avec ses parois
rigoureusement lys qui jaillissent le
loup cristalline avec son plafond au plo
la caverne passe en plein coeur de la
ville sous l'arrondissement de
saint-léonard à montréal
c'est le prolongement d'une petite
cavité qui était déjà connue sous parc
pie xii d'avoir une caverne shoes une
ville aussi belle et qui en plus est
déjà utilisée pour des fins éducatives
et qui subitement deviez dix fois plus
grande qu autrefois c'est phénoménal
la découverte a soulevé des inquiétudes
chez les résidents on veut s'assurer que
la caverne ne menace pas la sécurité des
maisons qui se trouvent au dessus
la ville a mandaté le géomorphologue
jacques robert pour cartographier la
cavité d'après le rapport remis à la
municipalité la caverne fait près de 2
150 mètres de long
elle fasse sous le boulevard lavoisier
puis s'étire sous deux pâtés de maisons
on a aussi mesurer l'épaisseur de la
voûte entre le plafond de la caverne et
la rue on a au minimum six mètres dont
la partie la plus basse et du calcaire
massif dans ces conditions là on
considère qu'en fonction de la largeur
de la cavité par rapport à la hauteur
jusqu'à la rue on est dans une situation
tout à fait sécuritaire selon le
géomorphologue les parois et le plafond
sont parfaitement stable la galerie qui
ne fait que deux mètres et demi de
largeur en moyenne compromet pas la
sécurité des maisons et si dominic
forget radio-canada à montréal